there's been some chat on Pro Vagner
telegram groups saying we will get
revenge watch out Kremlin we have no
idea how serious those are I think most
people discount the possibility of a
second Vagner Mutiny uh just Vagner but
the bigger question is what about all
the soldiers generals and officers
security service people bloggers who
supported Boran and why did they support
pran they supported pran because pran
they thought was the only guy really
fighting a serious war in Ukraine while
all the rest were being incompetent and
stealing which is probably true some
kind of new head of this Hydra is kind
of going to be dangerous and threatening
to Putin going forward because if the
war doesn't go very well there's going
to be other people who thought like pran
did and uh we can't exclude that they're
going to appear on the political scene
at some point in the future